apple co-founders steve jobs and steve
wozniak are famous for being at the
forefront of technological innovation
they literally built one of the most
valuable companies in the world but
steve wozniak has also been all in on
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies for a while
now he understands how disruptive this
technology is so we've got this quote
here recently he said that bitcoin is
mathematics mathematical purity there
can never be another bitcoin created
bitcoin doesn't even have a creator that
we know of bitcoin isn't run by some
company it's just mathematically pure
and i believe nature over humans always
steve wozniak now of course this is
great he's very very bullish on bitcoin
so what the hell does he think about all
of the other cryptocurrencies all these
other projects well steve recently went
on stevo's podcast and he had some fire
to say he basically thinks it's all a
scam here's exactly what he said humans
have learned and can put into books
methods of doing it some countries have
even disallowed crypto on blockchain
technologies it can be used a lot i
think it's being used a lot these days
to rip people off
i'll start a crypto i'll hire an
engineer that knows how to create it and
i'll get a celebrity to back it up you
know and we'll put out the um
the kim coin kim kardashian or something
like that that's probably a bad example
but um it's a great example it's a great
example it is it's a really good one
okay because i don't do social web so i
don't really
know the names to use but we'll call and
i see that happening all the time and
then the founders that started it pull
off some millions of dollars right away
from investors that say i want to get in
quick and early when it's young because
it's gonna grow like bitcoin i'll make a
billion out of out of pennies
and they jump in and then it goes to
zero that's the common story it's not
the only story there's some others that
are that made it for a while for
some good reasons yeah so i'm kind of
nfts fall into that category too the
number of people getting ripped off on
crypto and nfts is just just outrageous
now bitcoin is safe because it's the big
elephant on the block it's stable right
like conservative conservative thinking
you go for the big ones now of course
it's amazing to see the apple co-founder
talking about bitcoin in such a great
way he understands the technology he
understands the potential impact on the
world he's very bullish on where bitcoin
is going but to also see him highlight
the fact that many people are taking
these technologies or simply the hype in
the industry and using it to scam folks
or create all sorts of nefarious
activity that needs to be called out and
it's great to see steve wozniak
co-founder of apple doing exactly that
i'm very interested to see how this
plays out moving forward but one thing's
for sure steve wozniak he saw the
personal computing revolution coming and
now he sees the bitcoin revolution
coming as well hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time